i have no problem with
society opening up
the option
of more feminine behavior
on the part of men
and
as well as having opened up the option
of more
masculine behavior on the part of women
but we're not just doing that we're
making the feminine behavior as the
superior behavior and the masculine
favor as the toxic masculinity
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
political scientist an activist and a
prolific author including of his latest
book the boy crisis dr warren farrell
welcome to trigonometry thank you i'm
looking forward to being with you both
yeah it's such a pleasure to have you on
the show we're going to talk about some
subjects that are fairly controversial
in our society at the moment and fairly
difficult to discuss so i think before
we get into them it's important
for people to understand your background
because you were actually one of the
first men to be involved with the
women's movement all the way back when
uh and it's been quite a radical journey
for you since so talk to us a little bit
about your life story how are you where
you are what's been the journey that
brings you to be here talking to us
about the boy crisis
oh sure um in about i guess it was about
1969 i was in new york doing my
doctorate at nyu
um and the women's movement surfaced and
i took an interest in it and i was
teaching also at rutgers at that time at
rutgers university in new jersey and the
students when i was talking about the
women's movement they were really saying
you know you you're you have fire in
your belly uh warren when you're talking
about the women's movement you know um
and they said well what are you doing
your dissertation on and i said what it
was and they said you should think about
changing it to the um something on the
politics of the women's movement because
my doctor was in political science
and so um they i ended up convincing my
um
my the the people of the
my doctoral committee i was very
reluctant they said you know oh no this
is um you know this is just a fad it's
going to go away very soon and i said no
i disagree with that i think that it's
um
that there's an evolutionary shift
happening and the shift is that we know
up until this point in history in most
developed nations we were concerned with
survival and
when you're concerned with survival you
have to have very strict roles to to be
able to do whatever helps your your your
generation survive
women's roles raise children men's roles
raise money and so i think that that's
going to become much more flexible for
both sexes
and they sort of rolled their eyes but
at that point i had been
also appointed to be assistant to the
president of nyu so was i i was in
somewhere way as their boss
at that point as a student and so they
sort of backed off um and said and let
me do my thing
and um and that got me immersed in the
women's movement and and then i to as
part of my research i joined uh now the
national organization for women in new
york city
that led long story short to my being
elected to the board of directors of the
national organization for women in new
york city and uh and that led to my uh
speaking around the world on women's
issues
and that um you know that lasted um a
few years a number of years about half a
decade and um but then in the um mid 70s
early mid 70s i began to see that there
were a lot of divorces and i began to
see the first bit of research
that was suggesting that children who
did not have fathers a lot of father
involvement after divorce were not doing
very well and so i brought this up to
the board of now
and they responded well you know warren
women who are joined now
they want the option of being with their
children full-time or not if they
divorce they want the option to divorce
and the option of being with their
children uh full-time if they divorce
and so um i said well
but don't you care whether or not it's
the best for the children
and and they said listen you know we do
care that it's the best for the whether
that it's best for the children however
there's um
there's a bigger issue here which is
that we have lots of uh fish to fry it's
not just custody issues and we have
equal pay issues and sports issues and
so on and so we can't afford to lose
membership and so i'm saying i can
understand this politically but i um but
to sacrifice our children because it's
best politically is not a good trade-off
from my perspective and
and i said you know women i'm a 100 in
favor of women having the option to have
children or not have children of course
but once a woman chooses to have a child
that's like me choosing to take on a job
i make a commitment to that job i show
up every day and if i make a commitment
to have a child i put the child before
me
and if it looks like the child does best
when there's fathers and mothers both
involved
then i have to pay attention to what is
best for that child and not what is best
for me
um primarily unless it's so not best for
me so to speak
that that there would be
that that would end up hurting the child
and so we went back and forth on this
but i could see that you know i had said
that you know the the research wasn't
thorough at that point because you know
in order to find out whether something's
best for the child you have to not only
look at one point in history you have to
wait for the child to get to be 15 20 25
30 to see how that child longitudinally
does well or poorly and so i acknowledge
that that was not something we had
enough longitudinal data to prove one
way or the other
and they sort of basically said
well you know warren we thought you were
really a big supporter of us um and you
know you realize that all over the world
you the reasons you're speaking all over
the world and on all these tv shows and
you know and getting famous is because
you know is the recommendations of us
and so why don't you continue doing your
research you acknowledge yourself that
you know that it's uh you don't have
enough longitudinal data
well i can see the handwriting on the
wall was basically uh
um you know it's going to be the end of
my um career the you know the income i
was producing etc etc if i chose to um
you know just follow the research
without regard for the politics and
but i did choose to just follow the
research and but increasingly the
research to a much greater degree than i
would have even predicted at the time
showed that children who
were growing up with uh that were dad
deprived those children were doing worse
in all countries where there were
significant percentages
of
of children
that were being raised without their
dads um the uk the united states uh to a
slightly lesser degree germany uh all of
this was um being you know it became
very clear so i did start speaking up
about that
and you know everything that um you know
that was part of my infrastructure for
producing income and every article i
used to write for the new york times
used to be published and once i started
to explain boys and men's positions they
were not published anymore for the next
29 articles um and you know and the all
the tv shows the oprah's and
show so on that i would be on um they
stopped calling me etc and so it was uh
you know i went from doing extremely
well financially to you know doing much
more marginally but fortunately i'm a
reasonably decent business person and
was able to invest the money i had made
during the women's movement in order to
support myself being able to share
a more full story of what was happening
with boys and men
and in your book you detail and
excruciating detail the some of the
things that are happening and have
happened since since those days
particularly obviously to boys and men
um
for people who haven't yet read the book
i'm sure lots of people will go out and
buy after this interview but for people
who haven't read it in a nutshell what
is the boy crisis what is it that is
happening to boys and men in our society
in your view
in all 53 of the largest developed
nations
boys are falling behind girls in every
single academic subject
but especially in reading and writing
and reading and writing are the two
biggest predictors of success or failure
um and so i started looking at why that
was the case and i'll get back to that
in a moment but the key word is
developed nations
um the second thing i was noticing is
that boys
in all the developed nations were um
having
uh they were having mental health
problems they were so from when boys and
girls for example are nine years of age
they're very really uh likely to commit
suicide but when they do commit commit
suicide it's about equally
between the ages of 10 and 14
boys commit suicide at twice the rate of
girls between the ages of 15 and 19 it's
four times the rate between the ages of
20 and 24
it is uh five times the rate of girls um
and so very few people know that and
or ask the question why is that the case
on the mental health level uh boys are
far more likely to
get in uh feels depressed to feel
that they
have no option but to to get involved
with being addicted to drugs or being
addicted to opioids about the opioid
deaths for boys versus girls is about
four to one in the united states about
five to one in canada
boys are far more likely to be addicted
to porn be addicted to video games girl
video game you know involvement is
actually healthy up to a point
but the point which men do
males are more likely to do it
especially certain types of males
that because it becomes addictive that
it becomes destructive
um and so those that's just the mental
health the physical health problems very
manifest boys are far more likely to be
obese uh therefore they're more likely
to not um attend school fully they're
more likely to have to drop out of their
grades are worse they have to drop out
of high school to a much greater degree
than girls do boys who drop out of high
school are far less likely to be
employed in their 20s boys who aren't
employed are more likely to live with
their parents
boys are 66 percent more likely in the
united states to live with their parents
between the ages of 25 and 31
and the average girl that i know who you
know goes out looking for a guy is not
looking at unemployment lines um or you
know and searching out parents basements
for boys to boys to have a children with
um and so these boys are you know
feeling not only like their losers
living with their parents but they're
also feeling like there's there's
they're they're they're deprived of
of sexual intimacy
and they feel like they're if they reach
out they're always going to be rejected
that often makes them depressed that
often makes them get into porn because
porn is access to a variety of
attractive women without fear of
rejection at a price that they can
afford and since they're not earning
money that's the price they can afford
so they get into porn but the problem
with one of the problems with porn aside
from it objectifying women is that it
also um it uses men um because it gets
men addicted to people with beautiful
women's bodies um first it's just the
body that he sees that gets it gets him
excited but after he's seen a few
hundred bodies he needs to move to some
type of sexual behavior and then more
advanced sexual behavior or more you
know
challenging sexual behavior
like like um watching a guy come in a
woman's face and then he gets finally he
gets to meet a real life woman and he's
so addicted to what porn has addicted
him to
in order to keep his excitement up uh
that the woman feels like she's a porn
object and she feels and so she and
because she is a porn object and so she
withdraws from him which only reinforces
his uh
feelings of being sexually rejected and
therefore addicted more to the porn so
there are so many vicious cycles like
this um that i talk about in the boy
crisis book uh that that boys uh are
involved with and and this so you know
obviously this is you know the academic
health uh the academic lack of academic
success leads to a lack of economic
success lack of economic success means
that girls aren't interested in you
leads to depression leads to sometimes
suicide leads to boys acting out so
you know when i started researching um
the mass uh shooters who were school
shooters so for example in the united
states in the 21st century there are
only five school shooters who have
killed more than 10 people um but whose
family backgrounds we know of and all
five of them one hundred percent are dad
deprived uh the isis recruits in the
united states um are almost all dad
deprived children including girl the
isis recruits smaller percentage of isis
recruits who are girls and so the
prisoners in the united states are 93
men
but of those 93 percent men about 90
percent are dead deprived and i base
this on my research going around from
prison to prison in california when i
ran for governor of california and um
and asking prisoners you know how many
had uh data involved dads when they were
growing up and about you know ten
percent did but the the other 90 did not
and so you know on and on and so i began
to look at you know why you know we're
boys having so many problems and it
really wasn't
all boys that were having problems it
was the percentage of boys who were dad
deprived
they were the ones that were having
problems and so i found out that the boy
crisis resides
where dads do not reside
so that was the beginning of my
exploration of well what you know what
is the connection between that
deprivation and the boy crisis you know
why what's what is the importance of
dads what and then i found that dad's
parent
very differently than mom's parent not
all dads and you know and i want to make
it clear also that many children grow up
with single mothers who are i mean
almost all single mothers that i know of
are devoted to their children and
they're overwhelmed in the work that
they do and they care enormously
um and and many children grow up with
single moms uh that do do well uh boys
as well um but uh
where you see the boys who don't do well
uh the great majority of those are
deprived of their of the of their
fathers and so i started asking the
question you know what is there their
dads do that moms that is different from
what moms do
and that's what really
fascinated me about the the differences
between dad style parenting and mom
style parenting and my findings um in
the boy crisis that that that made me
where i was able to report that the
children who do the best by a long shot
um are boys and girls who have
what i call checks and balance parenting
they have two parents that are actively
involved even if they're divorced they
have two parents that are actively
involved about 50 of the time they live
close to each other they communicate
well with each other they don't
ban-mouth each other and if the children
who are of divorce have those four must
do's
um 50 time with each parent
parents that live close to each other
parents that are involved with
communication counseling
so that they get on the same page with
each other and see each other's best
intent and children that do not hear any
bad mouthing from
mother to father or father to mother
those are the children i found of
divorce that do the best and the rest of
them that do the best are ones that are
in intact families
warren we're having this conversation
and you're telling me all these things
now i used to be a teacher i was a
teacher for 12 years but
to me this seems like common sense
everybody would listen to us would go
that makes absolute sense of course
but why is it taboo why is it taboo to
suddenly say that children need fathers
that if you come from a broken home
you're going to do less well your
chances are that you're not going to be
as successful you're not going to stay
in education as long your grades aren't
going to be as good your life outcomes
aren't going to be as positive why has
that suddenly become a taboo thing to
say
because it it reduces
the well i'll give you an example
in both the the last two major elections
i went out to iowa where the
presidential candidates
are beginning to try to make their mark
and i interviewed um in at one point um
all republicans and another point all
democrats and the republicans tended to
agree with me on this issue and they
they said yeah this only makes it you
said common sense and um i was able to
talk to andrew yang who was a leading
candidate at that time in john
hickenlooper who was a candidate at that
time as well who's now a u.s senator and
after i talked with andre yang who
really understood the importance of
fathers the importance of families and
the import and the fact that boys were
in crisis
um the
the campaign manager overheard me and um
and andrew yang was she could see andrew
yang was really excited and the campaign
manager pulls me aside and says um
you know uh dr farrell
we have a problem here because if if if
andrew yang speaks up about these boys
issues
that are that's going to make many of
our feminist followers feels feel like
he's pro
male and anti-female and if he's and
we're going to lose a lot of our
feminist base and it's also it's going
to make a lot of single mothers feel
like they're not adequate and that's
going to lose this a single mother base
and our single mother base is largely a
democratic pace and um and our um
and the p and the women who
want to raise children um by themselves
that's what they're largely a democratic
base and the feminists will turn against
us if we start losing our feminist base
there's no way we're going to win the
democratic nomination
and you know after that andrew yang did
not speak up and i had the same
experience with john hickenlooper very
understanding very compassionate
wonderful man
really understa understood these issues
very well and had a good hour-long
interview with him educating him about
this
and
and so but the same reaction from the
campaign manager whereas i went to the
white house under the trump
administration
to brief them on the boy crisis book and
there's 14 people sitting around not
just from the white house but also from
hhs health and human services also from
the department of justice
and they're all going you know my god
you know on some level everything you're
saying is obvious on another level
you're giving us precise data as to
understand why we under you know we
understood that fathers were important
but we didn't understand what the value
of rough housing was for example
and and we would never have suggested
that the value of roughhousing among its
values was postponed gratification
among the values of postponed
gratification is that it's postponed
gratification is the biggest predictor
of success or failure and we never would
have predicted that roughhousing was a
predictor of empathy and and when you're
telling us why and how it's a predictor
of empathy all that makes sense but
that's
you know we couldn't no man that we know
says to his wife um you know i'd like to
roughhouse with the children so it'll
help them be more empathetic the
connection is counterintuitive and this
is what this is what we're learning from
you and so uh it was it was these types
of you know seven major differences and
a number of minor differences between
uh dad style parenting and mom style
parenting that really what the eye
openers
you know that i that i i think i was
able to find when i researched the boy
crisis book is to know exactly what the
dynamics were that lead to so many
children doing so much better when they
have both um dad style parenting and mom
style parenting in their life
warren
it seems to me that we don't take this
crisis seriously enough and i'll give
you an example a few weeks ago i was
reading about um education results in
the uk
and they were saying what you were
saying girls far outperformed boys
and the times in the uk wrote this
quasi-jokey piece about how maybe girls
were just smarter
and they couldn't have done that the
other way around
because if they did that the other way
to see them try yeah
maybe men are just smarter that would
make a great title yes yes exactly
maybe men
have achieved more and earn more money
because
even if they're not intellectually
smarter they know how to balance all of
the uh the parameters of life better
than women do can you imagine a headline
like that
but my question is why is that
acceptable to do that
and you know we talk about you know male
mental health you know suicide rates
going through the roof you know
more and more men feeling displaced from
society feeling angry the rise of the
incel culture
but yet it's acceptable to write a piece
about that i don't get it
here's why and this is not an easy
answer to hear
and it's going to take us deep
um and the brief reason the headline
reason is that
the reason we males exist as humans
and as animals all the way from insects
to human beings
is we exist
to be willing to die
to protect women
the essence of masculinity is the
preparation for disposability
in every war
men were told you will be a real man
if you um if you know in the united
states we said uncle sam needs you
boys you know grew up and they saw
their you know the uncle joe with a
marine uniform on and everybody talked
about uncle joe as a hero who died when
he was 17 or 18
in world war one and he um you know and
when the boy is being criticized by his
mother his father and mocked by other
kids at school he says all right there's
a way i can be a hero and that way that
he can be a hero is to be willing to be
disposable in that generation's war
and to think that he will be that he
will be a hero that he will be respected
and he's disposable
in order to be able to save
all the women in the in the society
and the the children
and other males that aren't in in that
war or weren't courageous enough to join
that war
and if he's if it's not wartime he's
learns that he also needs to be
historically um in the last in previous
generations he needed to learn that he
learned that he needed to be the primary
breadwinner that he needed to earn money
and so he learned to climb the ladder
of um
of success and not to ask himself
what do
should i do what i want to do what do i
want to do
but what do i
need to do to earn more money when i was
uh when it was a parent when i was in
high school that i i might be a decent
writer
my my father you know took me aside and
said warren you are a good writer but
you know um
only about one out of 100 you know
writers even get a publisher and if you
can't find a publisher you'll never find
a wife at least not a good wife that one
that's not worthy of you and so you
gotta you know drop this little dream
warrant of being you know a writer
and and even after i published my first
book and got a very good advance for it
he said that's right you got a good
advance you lucked out but um you know
um
supporting a family is not about lucking
out once and then taking a chance with
your family after that it's about doing
what you need to do more and it's not
doing what you want to do so get out of
your mind the focus on doing what you
want to do or what you're quote gifted
at
do what you need to do which is raise
money that's predictable and dependable
so you can support a wife and children
and family now fortunately in the last
generation or two women have shared a
lot more many women have shared a lot
more of that burden but even women who
do share more of that burden are usually
looking for men to marry if they want to
have children
if they want to have children they're
looking for men to marry who are earning
at least as much or more than they or
soon will have the potential for earning
as much or more than they to give them
the option of being full-time with the
children part-time with the children or
or full-time in the workplace
and so men learn men are still learning
today
that if they're not if they're not doing
what they need to do they're not going
to be wanted by women and so we often
hear that the pay gap is about men
earning more than women for the same
work that's not true what the pay gap is
about is dads who do earn more than moms
but not for the same work
men will tend to give up if you have a
you know a a young german
male who's you know
on the next train to be the next beatles
well he may not know he's on the next
train to be the next beatles um
practicing in germany um whether he's in
england or in germany um and uh he but
it's a risk that he will be only about
one in ten thousand will become the you
know the next beatles if that you know
that's probably an exaggeration in terms
of the percentage that will become uh so
he's worried that he's not going to be
able to make a good living doing that or
let's say he's an elementary school
teacher and he's passionate about
teaching his children
children come along and he says you know
i can make twice as much money as a
superintendent of schools or a principal
of schools i'll have to work much more i
i hate administration but i will give up
what i want to do being a great
elementary school teacher being an
artist a writer an actor or a musician
and i'll do what i need to do to earn
more money to be able to give my wife
the option of working as much or as
little as she wants while the children
are being raised and so therefore those
men end up earning much more money doing
but and what we in the feminist movement
did is said ah men earn more money
um
therefore they they have more privilege
they have more power
in fact men were forfeiting privilege
and forfeiting power because the road to
high pay is a toll road men were willing
to pay more tolls to get more money to
give up the things they wanted to do
which is not power it is the sacrifice
of power and the sacrifice of privilege
and so because nobody virtually nobody
understands this and i think i explained
this best probably in um
in both the boy crisis and the myth of
male power
because nobody understands this that it
becomes taboo
to write about the privileged as if
they're not privileged and that has
seeped into our culture at the
elementary school level um i hear kids
telling me in this fourth fifth sixth
seventh grade that their teachers are
talking about men who have power and men
who have privilege and and and women who
are living longer and
and living to be older and and not
having enough medicare and medic and not
enough social supports when they live
older particularly in the united states
and without any turning to the fact that
wait a minute
what about the people dying sooner
who has more advantage is it is it an
advantage to die uh sooner um
rather than just have uh certain
disadvantages when you are living longer
lauren uh let me ask you something
because when francis asked you about uh
why things have become tabooed seems to
me that there's
a a thing underpinning all of this that
i find incredibly wrong and distasteful
which is we've somehow ended up in a
position where
uh the relationship between men and
women is seen primarily through the
prism of competition when
that is frankly absurd historically
isn't biologically evolutionarily
historically to to suggest that men and
women should be in competition with each
other instead of on collaboration
it's the most self-destructive way of
looking at this whole thing that you
could possibly imagine isn't it
i could not agree more um the you know
part of what i say in the boy crisis is
that you know rather than think about
competition between men when
men
men when women lose
basically we are all in the same family
boat when only one sex wins everybody
loses and this is something that that we
in the feminist movement and as you know
my background was as a you know
speaking around the world as a male
feminist um and the um and uh this is a
mis huge mistake that we made um it was
like you know women are put down men
women must be oppressed by men um men
are earning more money we must be the
oppressors as opposed to understanding
everything i was just mentioning you to
you a few moments ago that that
biologically and historically if you
look at
the the up earning money as a toll road
very frequently and yes it if you if
you're one of the one percent or so that
earns a great deal of money um you've
usually sacrificed your life to do that
you usually will go to your deathbed
saying i wish i spent more time with my
family
you'll be usually disconnected from your
feelings in order to be able to repress
your of your fears and your feelings of
inadequacy in order to prove yourself in
order to not acknowledge any weakness
that other people can take advantage of
in order to become quote successful and
you're successful at work but you're
often
successful as a human doing
not as a human being
we often said you know if women go to a
party and they're single um and they're
looking for a future husband um the the
other woman at the party says oh you
know go over there to warren his books
are selling really well
go over there to you know joe he's a
doctor go he's so and so uh he's in law
school he'll be making a lot of money
he's really sharp uh they don't say you
know there's a sensitive loving you know
francis guy look at look at how sweet he
is uh why don't you go over and make
contact with francis he really listens
better than most people do and you'll
feel really hurt by him um and so it's
it's really destructive to see men and
women
as opponents because you know great you
know in my couple i do couples
communication workshops around the
united states and in my couples
workshops about a third of the people
are there on the on the verge of divorce
um and yet i have people make secret
little
notes uh to write in a piece of paper if
your partner
is life was in jeopardy and there was a
hundred percent chance that they will
die
um but you knew that you could um
you could save them
and you'd have 100 chance of saving them
but a 50 chance that you would lose your
life in the process
would you do it now remember a third of
the people in the workshop are
considering divorce
and 90
between 90 and 95 of the men
say nevertheless that they would be
willing to risk their life at the 50
level and or if they had 100 guarantee
that they could save the life of this
woman that they might be divorcing or
breaking up from
um and as well as the ones who you know
are there just to improve their
relationships when when women are asked
the same question and this is all done
secretly the partners never find out
what the answers are
it's about 75 80
of the women still feel that way as well
and so
most mostly men and women will forfeit
an enormous amount
to to save their partner to be
connected with the other one and yet as
you mentioned we're treating uh men and
women as if they're competing with each
other um and the
the gain of one is the loss of the other
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 percent off with the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
warren do you think and you touched on
this in your book that society has
become more and more and more feminized
when you come especially when you
compare it to 50 60 years ago
definitely and it's and i have no
problem with
society opening up
the option
of more feminine behavior on the part of
men
as well as having opened up the option
of more
masculine behavior on the part of women
but we're not just doing that we're
making the feminine behavior as the
superior behavior and the masculine
favor as the toxic masculinity
and there is a lot of toxicity in both
sexes both sexes that took their
femininity or masculinity to the extreme
both sexes became toxic in the process
and so women women who would were not
ever comfortable taking a sexual
initiative
directly
had to learn to take sexual initiatives
indirectly
if they didn't learn to take sexual
initiatives indirectly directly which is
a type of manipulation
they then then they didn't get a man
that they wanted they didn't get a man
that they wanted they were often very
unhappy
and so women developed a lot of toxic
behavior if they weren't able to express
a more masculine side of taking the risk
of asking a man out taking the risk of
sexual rejection
taking the risks of starting a business
that might fail
and so
it was very helpful for women to learn
male skills but either gender skills
taken to their extreme became
toxic on the male side of the coin
men
in order to be loved had to be willing
to risk their lives like dying in war
risk their lives um in a different way
by you know working either if they're a
working-class male in the hazardous jobs
as we as i'm sure is true in europe um
there's about 93
of the most uh of the people that has
who die in hazardous jobs are males and
those are the ones that just die in
hazardous jobs ones that die in
jobs that have what is called remnant
deaths like black lung disease from
working in coal mines where you don't
are as a firefighter you don't die right
away on the job you die much earlier
after you leave your job
because of the black lung disease etc
those are almost all men uh so these um
this so if you're in a boot camp and you
learn that your job
is to um to be willing to die for your
country
and the the sergeant or the the person
above you the officer in the boot camp
says you know
make some anti-semitic comments or some
um anti-female or anti-male comments and
um
you're let's say short he makes a
comment about being you know a little a
pygmy or a [ __ ] and you say that's you
know really racist or that's sexist or
uh you know or that's anti-semitic
the the job of that officer in the army
is to tell you um oh you sweet little
boy you're going to make a really
wonderful soldier worrying about what's
anti-semitic your job is to die
to be part of the war machine your job
is to be a cog in the war machine the
war machine does not work well with
squeaky wheels like you um get down and
do five push-ups get down and do 20
push-ups if that doesn't work get down
to do 40 push-ups guys
you have permission to mock this guy
until he gets straightened straightens
up and he stops being concerned about
who he is and what his sensitivity is
and um fo and focuses on recognizing
that he's here to be willing to die
so this country can survive and to live
and so um and now does that develop
toxicities it certainly does it means
you you know men learned
to not be even in touch with their
feelings um it wasn't that we just
learned to not express our feelings we
learned that men are very bottom line
people and we learn that if you know
expressing our feelings doesn't get us
anywhere it really doesn't help to be in
touch with feelings we can't express so
we might as well repress even getting in
touch with those feelings and that's
toxic when you can't get in touch with
your feelings it comes out in different
ways you act out you hurt people you
become hurt inside of yourself and you
know hurt people hurt people and this is
um and so you see almost all your mass
shooters are very hurt people usually
not just dad deprived but usually deeply
hurting inside and they act they acted
out and so both sexes have toxicities
but we have framed the world in the last
um
50 years as there's you know there's
toxic masculinity and there's sort of if
you will superior femininity and that's
just a miscalculation of the
understanding of both sexes and warren
another thing that i found really
interesting was
the point that you made in the book
where you were talking about the men who
felt unheard these were liable to be
your brexit voters your trump voters
because the only way that they had of
actually making themselves heard was at
the ballot box yes yes and and trump was
sort of like
he was articulating
without worry about what he said
and just sort of like you know i'm going
to lambast it's going to land where it
does i'm going to tell the truth from
the way that a lot of people in the
united states who felt left out who felt
unheard
especially the more developed
the woke culture became the more
cancelling the cancel culture became the
more
junior high school teachers were saying
the future is female and boys were
feeling that you know i'm a male and i'm
hearing that the future is female that
it doesn't inspire me very much to do
really well in school and to really you
know watch out for my future because if
i succeed i'll be telling i'll be told
it's because i have male privilege if i
fail i'll be um you know i'll be
ignored um and so a lot of people felt
caught between a rock and a hard place
and it appeared to them like trump you
know for all the bully that he was was
just cutting you know cutting right
through that rather than sort of um
what they would think of as namby
pambying around saying everything with
precise sensitivity and precision uh
that so many politicians did on the on
the part of both the left and the right
and so
yes there was uh uh there's so much that
the the political left was not hearing
about what the uh average experience was
of the average person the average family
felt that there you know they saw their
for the father going out early in the
morning becoming that firefighter
becoming the logger doing the hazardous
job becoming uh working you know making
more money
at a career
but also sacrificing being away from the
children experiencing what i call the
father's catch 22 um the dad learning to
love his family by being away from the
love of his family most women got this
most families got this
but they didn't feel that the political
left got this and so when when trump was
willing to speak about these things
without any uh fear of stepping on toes
uh it felt like finally they had a
champion
that's that's very interesting and you
you alluded earlier when you were
talking to
uh to the kind of angry bitter young men
who often find themselves in positions
where they're so angry that they start
acting out and obviously the extreme end
of that is the mass shooters that you
talk about but there's a bigger
uh
seemingly a bigger culture a bigger
movement or a bigger group of people
who've been enabled by social media and
technology to congregate to share
thoughts to kind of
talk to each other
uh whether it's in cells or or whatever
that is
what should society's attitude be to
those people because i have to say
as a man who's always tried to embody
the traditional qualities of masculinity
which is you strive you work hard you
have ambition you have drive etc i do
struggle to have empathy i mean
just in general because i'm russian but
in particular to that group of
of people because i always there is a
kind of uh what now is fashionably
termed victim blaming in my psyche which
is like well why don't you get up off
the the couch and go and try and do
something and and of course
i recognize that factually based on what
you've said it's a lot more difficult
for them than it may be was for me when
i was growing up
well it's a very good question so let's
look at the words like in cell
in cell for the novice tuning in here
is means involuntarily celibate
in voluntarily celibate so these people
these men are saying that i don't want
to be celibate
i'd like to be sexual with a woman but
i'm in volunt but i i have to prevent
myself from doing it because you know
for example if i put my penis in a
woman's body i'm putting my life in her
hands
she can choose to have an abortion or
she can choose to sue me for support
if um if i if i prote if i have if she
decides to not abort and to have the
child i am sued and i'm sued for support
from that one sexual experience i put my
life in her hands there's if i want to
have equal access to that child because
even though i didn't intend to have the
child i nevertheless feel like i want to
help raise that child because i know
children
do best when
raised by both parents and i feel it's
only fair for me to be equally involved
and i'm being told that i can't i don't
have an option to be equally involved in
that child's life i only have an option
to pay for that child's support
and i see that in court after court i
don't have a you know more than a
little chance of winning and if i had a
chance of winning i'd at least have to
spend the equivalent of 150 a thousand
u.s dollars to to hire lawyers hire
expert witnesses hire people to convince
the judge to allow me to be a good
father
that feels too like too much of a risk
for sex
so
you and i our program constantin
to to work our rears off and to do what
we need to do you wouldn't be doing this
podcast if you were if you weren't that
type of male
i wouldn't be writing books if i wasn't
that type of male but not every male is
like that some men do not have you know
they may have been brought up by them
you know by without a dad themselves
they may not be as motivated they may
but they still are heterosexual they
still care for women but but it's too
complex uh it's too dangerous to be
involved it's like um somebody wanting
to
desiring enormously to ride a motorcycle
um and
and take risks riding that motorcycle
but then reading and understanding that
it's 36 times more likely that you're
going to get into an accident
per mile of motorcycle riding so you
give up what you want to do because it's
too dangerous to do it that's in cells
and basically that's the same psychology
behind men going their own way
however there's two types of things that
can come out of that when men going
their own way or
in cells
meeting together and get together and
sharing feelings and sharing their pains
and sharing their anger and sharing
sometimes hatred of women um because
they're so uh
that either can be very healing because
for for moments when we're angry um
and we feel vulnerable
anger is vulnerability's mask
and in any therapy group every therapist
knows that sometimes the uh the anger of
a woman or the anger of a man will be
exaggerated i hate my husband i wish he
was dead um i wish i had never met him i
wish i'd ever married him well
that's that is anger of course
that is a hatred of the moment of course
but almost always i learned this again
and again from doing my couples
communication workshops
anger
is vulnerability's mask
if you ask
what's the vulnerability behind this
anger
you have a totally different feeling
about what's happening
usually what happens is the anger is a
stage and having a chance to vent
feelings um is therapeutic as it is in a
therapist's office
and this is a very healing
men like this getting together
and venting can be very healing and
occasionally it can be very destructive
if they don't get off the venting and
move into a more constructive life now
for me a constructive life is not
withdrawing from women or withdrawing
from society for me a constructive life
is learning how to listen learning how
to uh interact learning how to um you
know work things through and you know i
i can write about what i feel and talk
about what i feel
and i'm able to make a living doing that
and but let's open our hearts to the
people who can't make a living doing
that they're not saying they're not
saying i want to destroy women i want to
hurt women
i don't want women good things for women
they're just saying it's too complex for
me um to be out there with women um i
need to withdraw and be by myself
and warren the the thing that really
struck me when i was reading your book
which i really loved actually it was
very very powerful
was
a fact
that really hit home which was
more people would prefer to have a girl
than have a boy
and that to me really hit home where the
problem is
and that it seems to be as a society we
seem to prefer those now yes yes
absolutely and
what i i think is at the beginning of
the boy crisis i tend to talk about this
and you know one of the ways this came
up was um i was you know with a a number
of people um in a dinner party and um
and you know one was a strong feminist
and another one was um you know a
minister and the other one was a former
governor of uh a state in the in the
country who's pretty well known
and um and so um and there were six of
us around there and so sam keane the
fellow that wrote um
uh
you know the book on
um
he um
he
just asked the question
if you were having a boy or girl today
you know which would you prefer
and five out of the six of us said a boy
and so i started asking myself i wonder
whether this is true more than in a
cherry-picked anecdotal type of way
and was able to see that you know the
data on nap today
the great majority of mothers and
fathers would prefer to have a girl even
though the fathers say oh i'd feel like
i could have a lot more fun with a boy
i'd have a lot more permission to play
soccer or football or
a rough house with him and you know
really tease them and stuff like that
but
so they if i ask the question
with whom would you feel like you'd have
more fun
raising
the fathers would say a boy
but if i ask them
who would you rather have
a boy or a girl the fathers and the
mothers both said a girl and the reason
the father said that when i
questioned the fathers on that and
confronted them they said because a girl
will have an easier option you have more
options in the world at this time
they'll be more supported they'll be
more loved i don't wanna i'm afraid to
bring a boy into the society at this
time and so this is statistically what
both
females mothers and fathers future
mothers and future fathers would both
today prefer to have a girl because they
feel the girl will have more options
more support emotionally
more support economically in this
society at this time and for the future
of their of their life
warren that's an interesting point we've
we're almost out of time but i want to
just before we ask you our last question
just pick up on that issue because i i
hear that and that makes sense
but there's also a part of me that
thinks if you have a boy in modern
society and he's you know smart and
talented and he's got the right
education whatever
surrounded by boys who who've not had
the same thing who've you know we see
increasing breakdown of the family
increasingly boys being encouraged not
to act like boys but at the end of the
day
i also see around me particularly among
young people that
masculine men i mean they're cleaning up
right they're doing very well
uh because they are such a contrast to
the rest of of their peers if you like
so isn't there also a truth to like if
you have a boy and he happens to be
hard-working and driven and have the
kind of traditional male qualities
they will do very well isn't that also
true well
on the attraction of the other gender
level if he's um if he has both mother
and father and is bringing him up so to
be able to
to have that checks and balance
parenting that leads to postponed
gratification combination of empathy
emotional intelligence and um hard you
know hard work intelligence as well
and uh if you want him to be attractive
to the sex he has to be also tall at
least as tall as the average male
because females reject shorter men um
very
very frequently um sorry mike
i'm tall enough mate
so the um
you know or that you know the shorter
man has to work even harder to to be
even more successful to compensate for
his height uh so the exactly and so the
good news about a uh children being
raised by both parents especially if
they're really involved um with them and
their balanced people themselves is that
the boy will make it through uh this um
this enormous maze of challenges and
probably be all the stronger for it um
but there but the males particularly
those without dads are really have a
huge um
amount of challenges uh before them and
that's and that is deeply sad and uh we
we really need to have um and so let me
just spend a moment talking to the
single mother that's listening here so
you know you may become depressed if i'm
talking about the you know the
importance of both parents being
involved and so the first thing to do if
you are a single mom is to make sure
that you
look at the parts of the boy crisis that
focus on what are the differences
between dad style parenting and mom
style parenting and what
is what's the value of each of those
differences and so you when you value
that what dads ten can contribute and
you let the dad know
why you value him and why you need him
in the child's life
remember almost all throughout history
when men were told they were needed like
uncle sam needs you
the government needs you to fight this
war men are willing to die if they feel
they'll be needed and be of value
contributing so if you understand what
men dads contribute and you communicate
that effectively to the dad the chances
of having him involved are great however
if for whatever reason the dad cannot be
involved make sure you get your children
involved in
what i call in the boy crisis book the
liberal arts of sports pick up team
sports team sports um sports like
gymnastics or tennis which are largely
based on your the development of your
own skills
discover why all those are necessary get
him get your son involved in the
equivalent of scouting
find in each of the sports good
good male coaches who are willing to
support him emotionally but also prod
him on and expect more of him
get mentors for him and have him
read in the boy crisis book why
being a mentor is even more important
for your son than being mentored both
are important
but a boy who has somebody to mentor
begins to take on psychologically
responsibilities
that make him feel like he's needed if
he succeeds as a role model to the boy
he's mentoring so look at there's many
many things you can do if you have the
equivalent of cub scouts and boy scouts
uh in your country get him get him
involved in that if you have if you have
a faith that you care about get him
involved in a faith-based organization
but make sure that the faith-based
leader gets your son involved in private
conversations and group conversations
with other boys his age
so that your son can discover that all
boys feel very similar vulnerabilities
that he's not alone he's not out
he doesn't need to withdraw and be
depressed because he feels nobody will
understand him these are just a few of
the many things that a single mom can do
both to get a thought the biological
father involved the stepfather
spend time reading why the stepfather is
very rarely a substitute for the
biological father
so all those things are important if
you're a single mom to know in order to
have the best your ch your child your
children um have the best chance of
doing well this is almost everything i'm
mentioning is true for our daughters as
well but it's just more uh true
intensely true for our sons
warren i would have happily have spoken
to you for another hour however our time
is up before we go we always have uh one
final question which is always what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
um
well
sort of sadly everything we've talked
about on this podcast
are is sort of a way the one series of
things
we should be talking about that we are
not talking about for the reasons i
mentioned
we need to do
with boys issues and the importance of
fathers particularly the importance of
fathers
and the understanding what the
differences are between dad and mom
style parenting
we need to make that the equivalent of
what the green party made the
environment um 40 50 70 years ago
when there was when nobody would hear
about the importance of the environment
and the green party lost election after
election articulating that but now most
of the world understands the importance
of paying attention to the environment
we need to be the political leaders
the school leaders we need to petition
and make sure our schools have good male
role models so girls
girls and boys don't go from an
all-female home to an all-female school
and then we look um quizzically at why
they get attracted to a gang or why they
get attracted to selling drugs these uh
we need to look at what we need to do
take responsibility politically
and in our schools and at home
uh for having children be raised by both
parents um
in a in a completely equally involved
way
dr warren farrell thank you so much for
coming on the show we will ask you a
couple of questions very quickly for our
supporters uh in but in the meantime
thanks so much for coming on the book is
called the boy crisis i thoroughly
recommend everybody gets it and thank
you all for watching at home uh we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one
or a raw show which always go out 7 p.m
uk time 2 p.m eastern standard take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below